- Our next session is
gonna be also different.
We're gonna look at music therapy.
This is something that came from
our planning and advisory committee,
and a family that I work with recommended
our next speaker so I'm
really excited to hear.
Pierre Brennan is a board
certified music therapist.
He's a board certified behavior analyst
and the founding director
of Behavioral Rhythms
and a developmental coach at
the Autism Center of Northern California.
He received his master's degree
in neurologic music therapy
from Colorado State University
and has a bachelor's degree
from UCLA in physiologic science
with additional studies
in ethnomusicology.
As a Peace Corps volunteer in West Africa
he collaborated with UNICEF,
the Safe Motherhood and
Child Survival Project,
and studied the drumming culture
of Konkomba warrior tribes.
Pierre, please join us.
(audience applauding)
- Alright great, well it's
a pleasure to be here.
Earlier Dennis and Matthew
were talking about inspiration
and it made me think back when
I was in elementary school,
they actually brought me into,
had me spend some time in
a classroom with children
with special needs and
developmental disabilities.
And I had no idea, you
know later my entire career
would be based on that
experience, so it's incredible.
You plant a seed and you have no idea
how that's gonna develop over time.
So yeah, inspiration is such an
important component to all of this.
So, let me get the, here we go.
So, after college I
needed some inspiration,
so I took the logical step of
going to live in an isolated village
in the middle of Africa.
(audience laughing)
So my background is in
physiology and I also studied
ethnomusicology, the
study of musical culture.
So I thought I could join the Peace Corps,
work on community health issues,
and also study the musical
culture of an African tribe.
When I went to Togo, I said
I really want to study.
I want to live with a culture that is
kind of like the most pure
culture and they said,
we know exactly where you need to go.
This one village in the north, Kidjaboun,
and the tribe that lived in
that area was a warrior tribe.
If you look down at Lome
down on the coast there
and there's a nice red line that goes
straight up through the north.
And the road was actually gonna go,
kinda head toward Bassar
and go through Gerin-Kuka
near where that red arrow is.
But the Konkomba lived
there so when the Germans
brought their first battalion through
they were able to make all the different
chiefs in all these villages going up.
They would give them
alcohol and they said,
sure, that sounds great keep on going.
When they landed in the
area of the Konkomba
they refused to participate in anything
that they had to offer so they wiped out
that first battalion
with their poison arrows.
The Germans brought another battalion
through and they wiped those out,
wiped all of them out too as well.
So now the road actually goes,
it goes to the right in Kara and cuts over
so that whole region doesn't have any,
they don't get supplies, there
are no roads, no electricity.
I've recently spoken to
a friend in the capital,
and he said we have cell phones now.
I'm like, oh that's great.
And he said, I'm like, how
do you charge it though?
He's like car batteries.
Okay, that makes sense,
we have cell phones, but no electricity.
And when I was in a
village, it was 700 people,
all one family, essentially the story goes
that one man flew over the land
and he saw the water source
and so he landed there
and took on probably
seven to eight wives and had 40 kids
and two or three generations later,
you have a village of 700, all one family.
And people would find their,
husbands would find their wives
from outside villages
during farmers' markets.
One thing I discovered, and
talking about inspiration,
when all the adults would go
off to the fields and work,
all the kids would come
to the white guy's house.
They, once again, the
Konkomba are very hesitant
to send their children to school,
anything that had to do with white people.
One time we were all sitting under a tree
and they said, (speaking
in foreign language),
was the word for white man,
and we're sitting there,
and I'm about a year
into my service there.
And they were talking about
(speaking in foreign language).
I'm like come on guys, my name is Pierre,
and they're like oh no, no, no.
We're talking about the government.
I'm like oh, white man and the government
is the same word, I got it, so.
(audience laughing)
But one thing I realized
when I was in that village,
children are like sponges,
they are just ready to learn.
And we, as professionals,
we have to figure out a
way to connect with them.
And music is such a great
way to connect with people.
There's a famous
ethnomusicologist, John Blacking,
who talked about the
different functions of music.
Often times in the West,
music tends to be more of a,
it's like an entertainment,
we watch videos on YouTube
and we have, I have my
entire music catalog
on my phone which is amazing.
We go to concerts, every
time we watch movies,
there's music in the background.
But also we can make music.
In Africa, it was something that
everyone participated in, in music making.
Every male in the village could
play drums amazingly well.
When I first came into my village,
I brought a little tiny drum
I'd bought in the capital,
a little tiny djembe drum, that
was actually the first time
they ever saw a djembe drum,
I actually introduced
an African djembe drum
to an African village
which was kind of odd.
And I played my little rhythm
and I went back into the house
and here's a four year old
boy and they started playing
my exact rhythm that I was playing.
And I've been playing drums for 17 years,
I thought I was pretty decent,
and here's a little boy
totally playing exactly what I did,
and they're all laughing, they're like oh,
here's the white guy's rhythm.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, so.
And so, this picture was taken during a,
in the sacred forest during a rain dance.
Actually I didn't know
where this forest was,
it was about a year and
a half into my time there
when they actually showed me where it was.
And you can see in the middle
they have this huge drum.
And that drum just echos,
you can hear that for miles, actually.
When they have a dance like this,
you can hear it for miles around.
And there's some circles in the middle,
all the women, it goes by height.
So the tallest woman all
the way down to little girls
at the end and there's
also a circle of men.
And they were singing
and the drums going on
at the same time, it's
a pretty amazing thing.
When there's funerals,
which are celebrations,
if someone's old enough and had a family,
this will go on for three
days, if someone passes,
the Konkomba will launch
this huge explosion,
you'll hear it from five miles away,
first thing in the morning,
and that means that no one
does anything for three days.
So imagine if all of a
sudden you got something
on your phone and said someone
passed away in this village
and you don't have,
you're just gonna gather
with all your friends
for the next three days,
and no one's gonna go to work.
So in this village, life came before work.
And in terms of inspiration,
I really thought about
just the power of music
and how music can unify people.
But there's also many
different functions of music.
You use music to teach as well
as to connect with others.
So let's talk about music therapy here.
Music therapy is the clinical
and evidence-based use
of musical interventions to
accomplish individualized goals
within a therapeutic relationship
by a credentialed
professional who has completed
an approved music therapy program.
Sometimes when I tell people
I'm a music therapist,
they say, music's so
therapeutic, and I totally agree,
music is incredibly therapeutic.
But a music therapist
has some extra skills
and knowledge base to really
use music in a therapeutic way
to address non-musical goals,
non-musical behavioral goals.
Some things that are not music therapy.
There is auditory integration therapy.
And this was developed
in France in the '90s.
And this now goes under different names,
but essentially at the
core of it is taking music,
especially modified music and
removing certain frequencies
and children listen to
these for 30 minute sessions
and there is actually a little machine
that would do this and the
United States actually banned
this machine because it does, it's just,
there's no evidence to support its use.
Here's a quote from the American Speech
Language Hearing Association,
"Despite approximately
one decade of practice
"in this country, this method has not met
"scientific standards
for efficacy and safety
"that would justify its inclusion
"as mainstream treatment
for these disorders."
So speech therapists are not ethically
allowed to use this type of therapy.
In addition, the American
Academy of Audiology,
American Academy of Pediatrics,
Educational Audiology Association,
and the New York State
Department of Health
also say that there's not enough evidence
to show that this is effective.
But a lot of people still use it.
But it is not music therapy.
So one music therapy
technique that's used,
so Gabrielle Giffords,
she was a United States
Representative from Arizona
who was tragically shot,
and in order to get her speech back,
she worked with a music therapist,
and they used melodic intonation therapy.
And melodic intonation therapy is used
in the rehabilitation
of expressive aphasia.
So and it's, melodic intonation therapy
is a combination of some
physical cues like tapping,
humming, singing, chanting,
and then eventually speaking.
So music really helped her
to be able to speak again.
So let's talk about music
therapy and working with
individuals with
developmental disabilities,
and my personal specialty is autism.
So music therapy, there
are some goal areas.
Social communication, so you
can teach language concepts,
also emotional regulation.
Some of the clients I work with,
they're not always in a good mood
and sometimes a lot of us are,
we might need a certain
song to cheer us up,
like we heard this morning.
And music has an
incredible ability to just
put us in a different emotional place.
Also maybe if people are sad,
they listen to sad music.
They really wanna fully feel
that emotional experience.
So music has an incredible amount of,
music can be used in
so many different ways,
you can use it to target
social communication,
emotional regulation, also motor movement.
You can use music to teach
various motor skills.
We have some pre-academic
skills, academic skills,
the ABC song, if the
ABC song wasn't around,
we probably wouldn't
know the entire alphabet.
(audience laughing)
Numbers, colors, I'm
thinking of the Hokey Pokey,
when there's music and movement
involved and you're saying
what you're doing, it
resonates with people.
Some cognitive skills,
I'm just thinking about
that 1-800-Kars4Kids, if that song
wasn't part of that commercial,
I would not know that phone number,
but because of the jingle, we
all know that phone number.
And there's also musical goals as well.
So music instruction, music making,
sharing that experience with other people.
So music as an intrinsically
rewarding experience.
Music is, for a lot of people,
just it really gets them excited.
Some of these kids, I just
bring out this big drum
and they start playing on it and this,
they are just so happy with it.
And once I have their attention,
they're playing the drum,
now it's a point of contact
and I can really connect
with them and now I can bring in,
maybe we can do Old MacDonald Had a Farm
and bring in different
objects and start bringing
some language concepts in there,
and maybe start targeting some
social communication goals as well.
And going back to my African experience,
that drum in the center
can be very powerful,
it's kind of a visual,
it's almost a visual cue.
They're just setting up the environment.
And also in the Konkomba dances,
people would move around the drum,
I've also found that moving around a drum
can be very organizing for a
lot of kids that I work with.
Enhanced perceptual functioning.
When I was in college, I remember going to
the sculpture garden
and seeing this enormous
sculpture of an eyeball, it was huge.
And my friend said, if
your eyes were that big,
would you see more?
And I was like what does that even mean?
Would you see more?
But I think for a lot of children
with autism specifically,
they are able to see
more and they hear more
or maybe hear less or
only certain frequencies,
or their sensory system is just
designed in a different way.
So the next video I have here
is a young child with autism
and it's, from my perspective,
it really seems like he is hearing more.
I have an instrument called a Vibra-Tone.
So it's not, I dunno if,
just more of a noise maker,
we're not really playing songs
based off of the Vibra-Tone,
but sometimes I'll use that instrument
to really capture the child's attention.
And sometimes I'll play the Vibra-Tone
and the mom might peek
in into the other room,
she's like, what is that, that is so cool.
Sometimes the parents are
more interested than the kids.
But let me show you a
quick little video here.
So it almost looks like we're not moving,
but he is hitting that and he's
listening to it very intensely.
(Vibra-Tone clanking and resonating)
So just the sensory
experience of sound can be,
it can really draw the attention
of a child into the moment.
And then from there, now
we're gonna add music on top
of that so if they're already
very attuned to the sound,
now music can be even more
of a motivating experience.
And it could capture their
attention, joint attention
is pivotal in language play
and social development.
Once again, that drum
being the point of contact
where you relate with other people,
maybe even non-verbally at first,
then just through music,
musical expression.
In my practice I also use
lots of visual support,
lots of photographs, picture symbols,
written words, which enhance the child's
active participation and understanding.
Pictures can be very powerful,
in the song Slippery Fish,
you have Slippery Fish swimming
through the water there
and gets eaten by a tuna fish,
and in between all of these,
the song goes on and it
stops and you put your hands
up to your mouth and say
oh no, it's been eaten by,
there's a tuna fish, there's a shark,
so there's multiple opportunities
to practice this and use gestures.
And once the child, once
they become familiar
with the patterning of the song,
they're more likely to do that
gesture, it becomes familiar,
they're saying I know how this song works
and now is the moment
I'm supposed to do this,
especially I can, I might
withhold one of the pictures.
So we'll get to the shark and
maybe we'll get to the octopus
and we'll stop, and now the child knows,
oh no, soon as he says oh no,
then the song can continue once again.
There's the enormous whale.
There was an old lady who swallowed flies.
Kids love this one.
There's the fly, I'm
not sure of all you guys
remember this song but we have
the lady swallowed the fly
and then she swallowed the
spider and then the bird
and the cat and dog and the goat, cow,
all the way over to the horse,
at which point the old
lady falls over and dies.
(audience laughing)
Remember one time I had a father,
did the song with the child,
you know kids, they don't,
from my perspective, it
doesn't really seem like
they're understanding what dying means,
it's just kind of a funny thing
and the old lady magically
comes back to life.
I remember a father one
time leaning in like,
what are you teaching my child?
(audience laughing)
Sometimes, I think adults,
we tend to overthink lyrics and songs.
Music can be used as a reinforcers.
I have Thomas the Tank Engine,
the theme song, on my iPhone,
and if I'm working with a child
and it's a really challenging child,
he's not really focused on
anything, that's my go-to.
I play Thomas the Tank Engine
and just all of a sudden
he freezes like, what, you know something,
where is that music coming from?
And then I'll stop it, and
maybe we'll sit in the chair,
and now he might be more
apt, I'll stop the song,
as soon as he does what I want him to do,
then the music continues, I
can use music as a reinforcer
to guide and shape his behavior.
So in addition to being a music therapist,
I'm also a behavior analyst,
but I refer to myself
as a developmental behaviorist.
ABA's powerful but I think sometimes that
it's easy to overlook the developmental
aspect of children growing up.
What's great about
music, it's an experience
that's just very natural and
can happen in the moment,
so it's not so much a
checklist kind of thing
where I'm just taking data constantly,
but I can use the principles of ABA
in a more natural way, and in a fun way.
So ABA's based on BF
Skinner's operant conditioning
with our antecedent, our
behavior, and our consequence.
So in this situation, I'm
using music as a consequence.
The Farmer in the Dell
was one of the first
musical interventions I
created at my internship,
actually at UCSF in the autism clinic.
I apologize for the song,
I have heard this song
thousands of times, children love this.
So essentially, I'll play the song,
and then each of these pieces
are little felt pieces.
And then I'll lay out
farmer, the wife, the child,
the nurse, and go all the
way down and repeat it
a couple times so the child sees
what's going on and the
music really draws them in.
Here, let me play the song here.
("Farmer in the Dell")
♫ The farmer in the dell,
the farmer in the dell
♫ Hi ho the derry-o,
♫ The farmer takes a wife,
the farmer takes a wife
- And once again, just the song repeats
over and over and over again, it's a very,
it's the same song every time,
so it's something familiar
that the child can really latch onto.
And what's amazing about
this simple song is that
I can lay out all these
pieces, teaching sequencing,
and then I might hide,
I might hide the dog,
or maybe place it across the room
and for a child with autism,
they might have a hard time
following my line of vision.
But if they're motivated by
this and they want the pattern,
a lot of the children with
autism has this need to complete.
So if the song stops in the middle,
they're gonna want to try to do
whatever it takes to
make the song continue.
So I might hide the dog in a
certain corner of the room,
and where is the dog?
Teach the language, where is the dog?
Oh, it's over there,
maybe (speaking quickly),
and I point to it, maybe it's nearby,
then I further point it, further away,
or maybe I just use my
eyes and kind of use this,
target some of these social communication
goals in the middle of the song.
Once again, kids are so inspirational.
At the end of the song,
the cheese stands alone,
I always ask the kid, why
does the cheese stand alone?
And this one kid says, 'cause it's food.
I'm like, oh right, he's like yeah,
the people and animals
and the food is different,
so it's food, the cheese stands alone.
(audience laughing)
Another thing that I do
with this Farmer in the Dell
is I might hold one of
the pieces in my hands.
What is it?
Maybe have the child
guess, it has four legs,
and it says meow, is it the cat?
Really modeling the language,
teaching the language,
and then generalizing the language
to other real life experiences outside of
the Farmer in the Dell experience.
And rhythm used as a temporal cue.
So rhythm and timing are
important in motor learning.
The video, I believe I'm gonna show next,
is a child with cerebral palsy
and we go back to the idea of
sometimes if someone's
blind, they can hear better,
or some of the kids that I work with
and the individuals I work with,
they might have particular disabilities,
but they have incredible strengths,
I have one child who's
an incredible savant.
He has a hard time putting
one Velcro strap on his shoe
but can play anything on the
piano in any key that he wants,
forwards and backwards, he's
never been taught any of this.
He can do this baroque bass
pattern in his left hand,
just completely amazing.
But coming back to this,
the rhythm can really drive
different patterns of motor learning
and really drive the ability to maybe just
use your fingers or
maybe in gait training.
So here's a video, and I'm just
using a really simple rhythm
at the keyboard and initially
it's really challenging
for him to move his fingers
in a synchronized way,
in a patterned way, but over time,
he's able to, he was able to do this.
This child also had perfect
pitch, it was pretty amazing.
I would play a chord, he
would be able to identify
each note in that chord, all
three notes in the chord.
If I played a seventh
chord, added a fourth note,
he's like wait, something's different,
'cause you're playing,
and he would let me know
what note I was playing.
So he'd be able to hear
four notes simultaneously.
It's pretty amazing.
(upbeat synthesized music)
(gentle piano music)
So once again, the rhythm is providing
a temporal cue to drive
the motor movements,
and the music being motivating for him.
The rhythm and music can also
be used in gait rehabilitation.
When I went to grad school,
Dr. Tau does a lot of work
on this with Parkinson's patients,
and they've shown that music and rhythm
can improve step cadence, stride length,
symmetry, and velocity over time,
so essentially someone might
have a hard time walking
in a coordinated way
and you start listening
to New York, New York and
the next thing you know,
you start where they're at,
you use the song New York, New York,
and they start in a place that matches
their current movement and
slowly increase the tempo
to the point where their
gait is improved remarkably.
Impelling and anticipatory nature
of rhythm promotes speech.
And music facilitates
non-propositional speech.
When I'm working, I was
just working with a child
a couple days ago and I was using
Old MacDonald Had a Farm and you know,
♫ Old MacDonald had a farm
All of a sudden, here's a child
who doesn't really speak and
♫ E-I-E-I-O
He knows that pattern, just the
rhythm and the music almost,
he must have had that,
just that need to complete,
he wants to fill in the gaps there.
It's the patterning of
music that really helps us
to chunk that information
to make sense of it.
Structure and patterning in
music can direct attention
toward language concepts
and social behavior.
This was this,
the same child that I was working with.
Once again, I had about two
sessions, pretty challenging,
not much vocal participation on his part.
And then I busted out Bingo, great song,
it's amazing how some of these songs
just really motivate kids,
so I start playing Bingo
and all of a sudden he
starts beating the drum,
the B-I-N-G-O, he got that,
and started verbally participating,
put the drum in front
of him, encouraged him,
next thing I know I tried
the Old MacDonald Had a Farm,
he starts singing that,
he started sharing,
we started singing just different songs,
the lyrics back and forth,
he was filling in the gaps.
And the next thing you know,
we're talking about
the window in my office
and that's a big window,
yeah, the smaller window.
So the music was really,
was the spark that created,
that helped to create this
conversation back and forth.
I met him where he was at,
possibly his world is fairly chaotic,
so music really brought some order to it.
And using a simple song like
Bingo just really made sense
to him and was something that he could,
something that we could share together,
and that encouraged his
vocal participation.
Simon Baron-Cohen talks
about individuals with autism
and they prefer patterned
or rule-oriented structures
and have difficulties with systems
that require a high degree of change.
And that's what music is,
is just repeating pattern,
Old MacDonald Had a Farm, Bingo,
The Farmer in the Dell,
these songs, they just cycle,
The Wheels on the Bus Go Round and Round.
It's just amazing how many
children know that song
and it's just the same song
that repeats over and over.
You can change the words and
sing in 20 different ways
and children will remain
engaged in that song
because that's something
that they're drawn toward
and something that they're familiar with.
Here's another example,
This Old Man using props,
teaching numbers, once
again I could maybe hide
some of these pieces, have it nearby,
teaching some pointing gestures
or maybe have the child
follow my line of vision
to some of these objects
and I could stop the song
in the middle and just
really draw the attention
to maybe a specific language concepts,
and then continue the song.
And then maybe this old man
might have a conversation,
or he might feel sad about something.
Yeah, these props are
incredible, and This Old Man,
it's a pretty long song,
it's 10 verses in the song.
And once again, it just
repeats over and over again.
Sometimes when I reach 10,
kids are like, why only 10?
Let's keep on going.
(audience laughing)
The rapid temporal processing hypothesis.
I'm going a little bit,
so once again, my focus,
my personal focus is working
with children with autism.
And let's see, the rapid
temporal processing hypothesis
says speech perception relies
on higher temporal resolution
of complex stimuli, making
the deficit in autism
a timing problem where
slower, repetitive sounds,
like in music, remain intact.
And it goes back, here's a talking drum,
this is someone from Kidjaboun
playing a talking drum.
Now with this drum, they're
actually able to talk with it.
So they, since these languages are tonal,
they're able to say things on the drum,
they could say my name,
they could say different
things about me, so there
might be a talking drum player
in the marketplace with his talking drum
and he would be able to
sing praises to someone
sitting by him or maybe insult someone
sitting a little bit further away
and people literally
understand what he's saying.
So once again, making that connection
with language and music.
Both music and speech use
pitch, timing, and timbre.
And they've actually done
some research that shows that
training on a musical instrument
changes subcortical
encoding of speech patterns
and can improve how
speech and noise is heard.
Music and language share underlying
cognitive and neural mechanisms.
Auditory processing
structures in the brain
respond in similar ways
to both speech and music.
So there's a lot of overlap between,
there's a lot of overlap
in the way that speech
and music is processed in
the brain and perceived.
Some language, we have
words as discrete elements
and they're combined to form sentences.
In music, we have individual
and simultaneous tones
in the form of intervals and chords
which combine to form
meaningful musical phrases.
Here's some additional
similarities in music and language,
we've got phonemes, basic sound units,
syntax, how sound units are organized,
semantics, meaning that is
assigned to sound sequences,
and pragmatics, rules that define
effective communicative interactions.
So my particular interest was in syntax.
Syntax is a set of principles that governs
the combination of discrete elements
into meaningful and structural sequences.
It's cognitive processing
of structural relations between events.
A little story, story, there was a study,
Ami Klin back in 1992 and '92,
and essentially what they did,
what he did, he had a teddy bear.
And on this teddy bear
had a couple buttons.
When a child pushed one of the buttons,
he would be able to hear the voice
of his mother reading a story.
When a child pushed the other button,
he would hear a bunch of
random sounds in a bar,
just like random noise,
you can't really hear
one particular voice but
just a crowd situation,
the noise of a crowd.
And what they found was,
children with autism
either didn't show any,
didn't show a preference
for either or they showed a preference
for the noise of the crowd,
whereas typically developing
children and children with
intellectual disability
preferred their mother's voice.
So I was wondering why is that happening?
And I was thinking perhaps there might
be deficits in the syntactic processing.
Now culture influences
syntactic development.
So people have a preference,
someone raised in a particular culture
will have a preference for
the music from that culture
as well as the language from that culture.
So I thought that if
I took an African song
that was similar, it was similar in tempo,
orchestration, and form, to
an American children's song
that a child with autism
should not show a preference
for either of those types of music.
If their syntactic development is,
if there's deficits in their language,
then the same should be true for music
since there's a lot of overlap
between those two regions,
between those, let's see here.
But I didn't find that,
which is good and bad.
It was puzzling because I
was thinking if a child with
autism doesn't show a preference
for his native language
then why does he show a preference
for American children's music?
And as you can see in the
graph, the children with autism,
in typically developing,
it's almost identical.
Children with intellectual
disability showed
a stronger preference for
American children's music.
The song that I used was The
Green Grass Grew All Around,
essentially I had two
buttons, you push one button,
and they would get 10
seconds of one type of music
and the music would stop
and they would choose
the same button or the other button.
And then I would change the location
of the buttons during the study.
And there's six children in each group.
And then I came across
the shared syntactic
integration resource hypothesis,
which made sense to me.
So essentially what this says
is that syntax is processed
in a shared system in the
frontal part of the brain.
But, then it splits off
to musical representations
and linguistic representations,
which are separate.
So someone might be able
to process syntax in music,
but not process, sorry,
so if a child is not
attending to language,
then they're not gonna make,
they're not gonna build up
that knowledge base of language.
But music is on a separate track,
so that might not be effective.
So a child with autism who
doesn't pick up on the syntax
in language, they might pick
up on the syntax in music.
And there's actually recent research
showing that the processing
of music and linguistic syntax
interact in Broca's area,
in that shared area.
Syntactic deficits in the study
appeared to be domain-specific,
implicating linguistic
syntactic representations
rather than shared syntactic processes.
So the issue here isn't the
syntactic processing of syntax,
'cause that seems to be intact,
because the children are
processing musical syntax,
but not processing the linguistic syntax.
So they're storing that
musical information
but not storing the
linguistic information.
So music's a language that a lot
of children with autism understand.
And a couple other things here,
music as a mnemonic device,
and I talked about that
1-800-Kars4Kids commercial,
and the ABC song.
Listening to music recruits attention
and working memory circuits,
and music training improves verbal memory.
Verbal learning with a
musical template increases
neuronal synchronization and approves,
improves, I should have
said, improves verbal memory.
So once again, music is a
way to chunk information
to make it more accessible,
to learn and to remember.
Also music can be used as
symbolic communication.
For some of these
children that I work with,
they have a hard time with conversation,
the back and forth exchange of ideas.
So I might designate one
instrument, let's say a drum,
that'll be the narration instrument,
the making comments instrument.
Or I might, and then I
might include a xylophone,
and that's the question instrument.
So initially we'll have
a nonverbal conversation,
a musical conversation,
so I'll play on the drum
a little bit and then maybe
ask a couple questions.
And we'll go back and forth like that,
very motivating for the child,
and that talk about what that meant.
How many comments did we make?
How many questions did we ask?
Are we asking enough questions?
So initially we're just using
music as a way to communicate
and then we can add
some processing to that.
Take away the music and then work on
just having a conversation,
so music is being used
as a way to help a child
understand that back and
forth exchange of ideas.
And also music as a social experience.
My personal frustration with being
a behavior analyst is I've seen,
it's sometimes the case where
it's more of a top down
kind of thing in ABA,
I'm gonna ask you a question,
you're gonna respond.
you're gonna respond,
I have a whole list of all these questions
we have to get through
before the session's over.
But from my experience,
and I've discovered that
if there's always just questions,
always a probing question's happening,
it takes away the inspiration of some of
these kids to initiate on their own.
So communication's a two way street.
If it was always people
need you to respond
to questions all the
time, maybe it shuts down
the ability to have that
back and forth exchange.
And what's great about music
is that music allows us
to have that back and
forth emotional experience.
And this last video I wanna
show you is of a child,
and I was wearing my ABA
hat and I was working
on something very specific before.
As I was putting away the
drum, this child with autism
loves playing this drum, he
could probably do it all day.
So he started playing it,
and then I started using that
as an opportunity to go with the moment,
just really enjoy that back and forth
exchange of musical ideas.
And then I was also started to
play some eye contact games,
so I was hiding behind the
drum, have him follow my eye,
moving to different sides of
the drum, behind the drum.
And then I was able to
use the rhythm of the drum
to really accent some language concepts.
I think initially he
says, that's a great song.
So I tried to, I'm like
yeah, it is a great song,
but this is fun, and I
think there's a point
where he says that is
fun, I try to correct him
to say this is fun and I'm
playing on the drum like,
(tapping)
this is fun.
And then he does it back and forth,
we play some more music, and
then I bring back that idea,
this is fun, driving home
that language concepts,
driving home that language,
or just that phrase,
just teaching him that
phrase in that moment.
And so it's something meaningful to him
and it makes sense to him and
then he was able to generalize
that phrase into other
environments after this experience.
(banging on drum)
And we can jump ahead here a minute,
just a little bit of a long clip.
That's good.
(banging on drum)
(child babbling)
Yay.
(banging on drum)
- That's a great job.
(laughing)
(banging on drum)
- This is fun.
This is fun.
(banging on drum)
- Gonna blow out the speaker.
(audience laughing)
We have an issue with the sound there?
Oh, don't know what happened.
Well without the sound,
it's kind of tough to see.
(laughing)
So essentially it goes
back and forth here,
and then I start playing
the rhythm, you know,
(tapping)
this is fun.
And then he repeats it back and forth,
and we get that idea, then I
go into just some more playful
communication going back and
forth, sharing that moment,
sharing that experience, and
then bringing back the idea
of this is fun and eventually
I'll say this is fun
without playing it on the drum.
Alright.
Great.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)